monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture
vous connaissez je le sais la détresse
extrême de nombreux agriculteurs qui
s'ouvre d'art qui souffrait d'un revenu
beaucoup trop faible il ya 18 mois
pour clore les états généraux de
l'alimentation le président de la
république nous affubler d'un discours
d'une grosse heure à discours
d'illusionniste 7 illusionnisme a été
traduit par une proposition
gouvernementale votée par l'assemblée
nationale de la loi et galim je sais
monsieur le ministre parce que j'ai
beaucoup d'estimé pour vous que dans le
fond de vous-même vous savez que cette
loi ne résoudra rien au niveau du revenu
agricole
et comme nous avons encore une certaine
confiance en vous pouvez vous nous dire
comment vous allez empoigné à bras le
corps véritablement le problème du
revenu des agriculteurs pour vous
répondre la parole est à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur michel
raison
je suis d'abord très heureux de vous
retrouver sur sur ses bancs après une
absence de quelques semaines et je lui
ouvre en très grande forme donc très
heureux de répondre à votre à votre
question savez monsieur le monsieur le
sénateur ce n'est pas de l'illusion de
l'illusion qui a fait le président de la
république a enregistré de la raison et
vous le savez très bien
nous étions unanimes nous étions
unanimes pour dire que si nous
continuons comme ça nous allions dans le
mur si nous laissions faire les
négociations commerciales telles
qu'elles se sont passées depuis dix ans
nous allions dans le mur
trois cent quarante mille agriculteurs
16 bis d'entreprises de transformation
quatre centrales d'achat et ce constat
nous le partageons toutes et tous la loi
a été mise derrière c'est un pari cette
loi l'expérimentation de l'ordonance le
seuil de revente à perte et pour deux
ans allons-y ensemble allons-y ensemble
et le gouvernement a pris conscience de
la détresse et du revenu des
agriculteurs dans le plf 2010 9
les baisses de charges les belges de
fiscalité dans tout un tas de secteurs
notamment le gazole non routier
le cic eux les baisses de charges pour
les peaux
écope font que le secteur de
l'agriculture et celui qui est le plus
bénéficiaire de baisse de charges et de
fiscalité
je voulais déjà dit si c'est absolument
une réalité les chiffres sont têtus
le budget est têtu et le rapporteur
général du budget ne me démentira pas
ensuite nous voulons aller beaucoup plus
loin et pour aller beaucoup plus loin
monsieur raison nous avons besoin de
tous de tous vous comme ceux de la
majorité
vous aimez les agriculteurs vous en vous
en étiez 1 vous voulez que les choses
réussissent alors monsieur raison aidez
nous à ce qu'elle réussisse aidez nous à
convaincre l'ensemble des acteurs de la
chaîne que ce que nous avons mis en
place doit marcher parce que si ça ne
marche pas c'est peut-être la dernière
station avant le désert et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il n'est pas temps
de tergiverser il n'est pas temps de se
dire il aurait fallu faire ceci ou faire
cela nous avons les outils dont les
mettre ensemble je vais mettre toute ma
force pour le faire et je sais que je
pourrai compter sur vous monsieur raison
monsieur raison merci monsieur le
ministre je suis en effet là pour vous
aider
mais surtout aider notre pays et vous
savez que si la colère a été si forte de
notre pays c'est l'addition de mensonges
après mensonge d'illusionnisme après
luzio nice et vous savez comme moi que
senna pas en essayant de modifier
quelques petites règles en matière de
négociation commerciale un cm2 le
comprendrais que ça va toucher quoi que
ce soit dans le revenu agricole elle
revenue vous l'avez dit est en effet
fait d'une colonne de prix de recettes
mais de charge aussi n'ai rien touché
aux charges le gasoil ya des années
qu'il est comme ça qu il ait des taxis
parce qu'on brûle pas le gasoil sur les
routes
monsieur le ministre empoignez deux
choses prioritairement les charges des
agriculteurs
la complexité administrative et
n'oubliez pas la réforme de la politique
agricole commune qui fait partie d'une
des recettes des agriculteurs le prix ça
n'est pas le levier du politique le
levier du politique c'est les charges et
la politique agricole commune
merci